we are here to celebrate one of this
city's greatest sports teams
the 1971 world series champion
pittsburgh
pirates 50 years ago this talented group
of men from all ethnicities and
backgrounds veterans and rookies came
together and played with grit passion
desire and drive
to lead the pirates to their fourth
world series
with our game time first pitch let's
hear it one more time his catcher
is milt may steve blass and it is will
crow
on the hill to make his 14th start jeff
mcneal
with nemo on it first
into right center and the catch made by
reynolds that ball hung up long enough
for reynolds to get a throw off and a
double play
whoa brian reynolds
toward the track in right center doubles
up
nimmo and for the mets tyler mcgill
and a little pop-up and look at this
i mean who knows if he doesn't get drawn
in and now frasier going for second and
he's there with a double
adam frazier just a little blooper
over third base for a double muscles
that ball out to left field just over
the third baseman's head barely onto the
grass
and turns it into a double i mean this
guy just hits her and still at second
base now with two outs frazier
one ball two strike count on him gammel
whoa goes after one that's up
nice comeback for miguel after the
lead-off double smith over four last
night
right to second boy that double play
ball was cool's friend last night and
it's
will crow's friend so far tonight that's
a beautiful thing what
well position guys right here frazier's
glove went right to him
fought that change up up with a really
good fastball that created that crown
ball i mean just a good job
all the way around polanco off the
injured list today he's been sidelined
since july the 6th
and goes the other way welcome back
gregory polanco
he goes really well it's when he hits
that ball out away from him and that was
so direct and so
simple you have to love what you just
saw right there for your pirates fan
stallings
shift on playing him to pull he'll take
the ball
right into that hole there's one running
throw and a good one
jeremy is uh very athletic here he comes
racing across
very nicely done wow alonzo now with
runners at first and third
bounced to short get a hurry one
and they do it again mr double play
one ball one strike delivery on the way
to him and that ball put him in the air
down the line
right field would give chase nice play
had a long run to go get that and able
to haul it in
the newman retired for the first out
here in the third inning
fraser let it off with a double his
first time up
and there's alonso now kicks off the
glove
and we'll see how they rule it alonzo
certainly feels like he should have had
it
and it is an e3 and right through that
hole
first and second working inside the
baseball and through the baseball
especially
with two strikes i feel like keith ryan
does a good job of that his entire bat
but especially with two strikes first
and second with two outs for reynolds
check swing goes to third charging davis
jd's throw
was he on the bag yes he was alonzo had
to stretch to keep that back foot there
to get the out
but they do it's a lead off walk here in
the fourth inning
and now jd davis will step in
oh he's going to be put up in the air it
is deep in center at the wall
and goodbye home run hey out there in
center field the deepest part of the
ballpark
and the mets are on the board as davis
comes back with a homer and the mets are
on top two to nothing
goes single in the second one out hit by
nagowski
he'll go after the first pitch put it
way up in the air
down the line near the pole and
hauled in a wall scraper conforto got
over there
right in the corner near the foul pole
and hauled it in and polanco's out of
there
all right you two aboard brings up kevin
newman
0-1 on the outside part of the plate
but a force at second base and that's
where they will get the elf
runners at first base coming up will be
jd davis
high fly ball deep to right field
polacco watches it fly
it's gone a home run for jd
davis and it is a four nothing lead
second career multi-homer game keys
fastball
belt high away and he knew it and boy oh
boy tell me that is it doesn't feel
great for him what a day
to come back here in the top of the
seventh keller's on in relief
chopped on by guillermo down to third
hayes charges and he gets past him and
that will be an error
on keep brian hayes as guillorme reaches
so blankenhorn gets the at-bat and got a
hold of that one in the air
towards right center field way back and
off the top of the wall it's in play
throw will come into the cutoff man
it'll be a double and a run scored
hanging slider for blankenhorn stays
back on it
a fan did reach over the yellow line
and it was hard to tell if that fan made
contact at all
so it'll stay as is the mets have
runners at the corners
one two delivery toy that one was away
it's gonna get a run in it's an rbi
single for jeff mcneal and a six-nothing
mets lead here in the seventh
so trevor may coming in it's his turn
mets have a loaded bullpen
kevin newman at the plate numino for two
pitch swung on and missed
newman down on strikes guy who does not
strike out very often the hardest player
in the majors to strike out but he spoke
out once last night and has done it here
again tonight
two on brings up keep ryan hayes way up
high over the glove of mccann to the
backstop
and the runners will move up to second
and third pirates the pitch on the
outside corner
paul strike three and looked a little
bit outside but meg got the benefit of
the doubt right there
as we go to the bullpen one more time
yeah seth lugo he is just an outstanding
pitcher
with smarts puts two on for nagowski
a line drive hit to left it's crazy what
he's done
gets the bucks on the board gamble
better be safe
he is whoa that would have been a no-no
but no-go doubles gamble to third
as there are two outs nagowski makes
third new minute first and wilmer defoe
fly ball to right field did he do it oh
wilmer defoe d-i-f-o
clears the deck with a cannonball
fireworks and a one-run game
he'll go to the ninth inning with the
mets on top
by one fastball hit in the air deep
towards center field
backboard is reynolds he's near the wall
that ball is gone
home run brandon nimmo the mits extend
their lead in the top of the ninth
inning
a much needed insurance run as nimo
smacks a solo homer
it is now seven to five the tying run is
in scoring position
now jacob stallings pirates last chance
here's the pitch
the fly ball to the left near the line
by the wall
and oh no way jacob stallings
just cleared the deck unbelievable
the bucks walk it off in grand
fashion